a man that has been playing the
character of Victor Newman on The Young
and the Restless which is in season 46
on CBS none other than the Emmy Award
winning actor Eric Braeden how are you
sir thank you rich I'm when I think of
it I've been on the thirty nine years
that's a hell of a long time you know
think of a run whoa it's a cover Rock
yeah yeah yeah I know God you were born
in 69 yes that's right I'm about to turn
50 11 years later when you were 11 years
old
you started why not yes he did you
imagine that I'm sure and I'm sure um
you know I I was flipping it on to knit
in I was a General Hospital guy growing
up but then I turned into us I know it's
the wrong show you know but then I
turned they're young and the restless'
I've seen it you know who else watches
General Hospital who's that Steven
Naismith see now let's get this yeah I'm
holding up the book right here yeah I'll
be damned which is your book that came
out a couple of years ago that's right
and it says at the bottom foreword by
Stephen a smell no Smith you know I have
known each other for a while I forget I
would have to ask my publicist long time
yeah great guy and I said you're
watching the wrong show so obviously you
are as well well I was I was I'm just
filling in when I first got into you
know when I was you know 10 11 or what
have you because you know but we're
touching on something here is that the
number of sports people athletes
especially who watch soap operas it's a
sleeper community it's amazing it's an
immense sleeper community right it
didn't interview with me on Sports
Illustrated the only time they ever
interviewed an actor because Franz Liszt
was the writer and he interviewed the
Yankees I said what do you do in your
time off so we watch soaps which one
wine are which character Victor so since
that
I've known that a lot of athletes watch
the show you get names drop me names
that have come up to you that you've met
ali muhammad ali holly was a fan
all right let's walk me through that why
holly was a fan and he had his 50th
birthday party at Jason's on Beverly
Boulevard
yo Jason's here in Los Angeles right and
he invited me and I took my son I
thought why would he invite me he's a
big fan of the show and then one day he
was a obviously enormous respect for the
man and his dealing he what's been a
plane from Philadelphia to LA and we
taught each other in the plane and then
we walked through LAX and I've never
seen anything like it
people stopped in their tracks to look
at him a champ from 6 to 90 all races
all ethnic groups doesn't mean different
right and he had a little time for
everyone that so impressed me the only
other person that impressed me along
those lines was Billy well sir met in
circumstances like that just showed nice
and giving with fans who is this pili ok
Pele biggest in the world circuit yeah
yeah Billy and Ali were the two most
famous athletes in the world was
paralyzed he was pale ear Wyatt Young
and the Restless no it was not he lives
in Brazil but then one day it's
worldwide you get 120 thousand daily
viewers worldwide 120 minutes 120
million reais right I've missed a couple
of zeros 190 million worldwide him so
then one day let me tell you at CBS
stage manager knocks at the door and
said do you mind if George Foreman says
oh no mm-hmm I said do I mind
yeah I'm a huge boxing fan I used to do
myself a little bit and he came in he
said where and I'm blessed and blessed I
said you have less my man I'm blessed
George Foreman well the hardest most
fearsome guys in the ring ever I have
not met Tyson but George Foreman early
too
euros but you're Eric Braeden who plays
Victor Newman on Young and the Restless
here in the Richards joke you're a
die-hard from what I've been told you FC
fan right you're locked into the UFC
well I'm a fan of look I left football
hmm love to watch football what's your
team in football uh well right now it's
the Rams again okay yeah I hated them
for a while because they left home
mm-hmm I used to be a fan after that of
the raiders hated them when they left
him and when the Rams came back I said
to hell with you and then now I'm slowly
becoming a difference I loved that Coach
McGrane he is one of the first guys I've
seen on the sidelines who doesn't have
that macho swagger you know he's a he's
a real guy and very smart unpretentious
yes you can see as real sterling sir
very smart guy and I now I'm becoming a
fan of the Rams again that's good I
remember Merlin Olsen rosey Grier Deacon
Jones Lamont Lundy the fearsome well
that's by the way all system good actors
in there too right
I think more rosin Merlin Olsen rosey
Grier's appeared on some things Deacon
Jones would appear on occasion and
something yes some for some that's how
long I've been a fan of the Rams for
sure in the 60 in they come back around
first game us on the old Coliseum
against the Vikings in 1963 is somewhere
around them and I hadn't seen football
before I'd come from Germany in 1959 and
I thought wow what a game that's right I
would have loved to have played the game
to be honest with you would have loved
not just hitting it off just some people
right so but you are a fan there any
specific fighter UFC fighter that you're
well I wanted to say arguably the best
ever bones Jones Jon bones Jones who
just fought against Smith yes he was so
dominant Jones bones Jones had his best
fight his hardest fight against
Gustafson the tall sweet at his same
height a little taller actually
great fighter great punches beyond that
Randy Couture all those old guys you
know enormous respect for them and
fiction Gracie the Gracie family brang
brought UFC or Brazilian jiu-jitsu to
America and they beat Restless the table
restless they beat the top boxes so
Brazilian jiu-jitsu Hagen Machado Dixon
Gracie the Gracie school of jiu-jitsu I
have a great great respect Eric Braeden
here on the Rich Eisen show and we're
noticed in a clip that we just showed in
our television overlay segment one of
your colleagues on Young and the
Restless who seems to be a young he's
very Sean McVeigh looking dude to be
allies with you that's right looking
bill sorry that sad looking with that
Luckinbill who produced who produce
Sicario okay 1 & 2
very good that's right all right so
you're in a scene where you go back and
forth with him and then you proceeded to
kick his ass now let me ask you this
question it looks like you is there
there's no stunt double the old Eric
Braeden boxing days I usually box in
70th and Hoover mmm howdy on the ghetto
mmm and Hunter eighth and Broadway and
in the real ghetto gyms okay so that's
the guy that we're seeing on screen
right now you're moving or moving yes
okay of course I still do keep fit okay
every morning I do 100 straits and 100
hooks and hundred uppercuts just to wake
up I drink coffee
keep it up never give up never give I
like in never okay you know I do I look
I look forward to living that every day
do not go gentle into this good night
rage rage rage against the dying of the
light
as Dylan Thomas remove the old Welsh
poet of course so I have here if you
don't mind
Eric braid
here on the Rich Eisen show we have
printed out word for word verbatim three
of the great sports rants of all time
and we would love for you to do your
best Victor Newman Michael Teufel has
the music the soap opera music I'm gonna
hand it to you right here if you
wouldn't mind I'll set them up for you
one by one and just you-you-you give us
the the good old Victor Newman college
stripes I don't know the first one is
her med much
yes Herm Edwards the first one up Herm
Edwards on October 30th 2002 after a
week eight loss to the Cleveland Browns
oh here is play to win the game as told
by Victor Newman aka so in other words
he's pissed off after losing the game
yes see it well and you know I coach my
son's team for 25 years on soccer okay
so I know what it means to be pissed off
as a coach okay that's your motivation
Mike tell to Phil hit it please this is
great about sports
there's what's the greatest thing about
sports is you play to win hello you play
to win the damn game right
you don't play just to play it that's
the great thing about sports you play to
win games and I don't care if you don't
have any wins you want to play to win
when you start telling me it doesn't
matter
get your out of here then retire cause
it matters
[Music]
well done that's number one
next up in October 16 2006 after the
Cardinals blew a 20-point lead against
the Bears on Monday Night Football
Dennis Green
they are who we thought they were as as
portrayed by Victor Newman they must
have heard hit hate it Mike dill too fun
[Music]
Bears are we thought they were you know
that's right because the damn field now
if you want to crown them then cranberry
but they are who we thought they were
and we let them off the damn hook good
all right last one [ __ ] feelin cuz
here's the last one on May 7th 2002 the
famed practice press conference of one
Allen Iverson as recounted by the man
who plays Victor Newman Eric Braeden hit
my god Goforth
I mean listen
your Dharma practice okay but a game not
a game not a game all right man we
taught my practice not a game not the
game that I could have then die for and
play every game like it's my last not
the game they talking about practice man
I mean what silly is that I know it's
important yeah I do I do I honestly do
hope you try my practice man what are we
talking about practice you told my
practice man Eric I think that's your
finest work if you don't mind me saying
well thank you very much I mean I've
done a lot you've been there you've done
that that may be your finest work of all
these guys I know you do Jesus being the
king he shows up various games I think
he lives in Atlanta I think some like
big threes doing the big three that's
right he doesn't play anything before I
let you go what was it like you worked
with Jim Brown just after he stepped off
the field right and then 100 rifles Jim
Brown finished playing in 66 right you
retired and did Dirty Dozen and then he
came and did hundred rifles 1969 in the
film we did in the south of Spain with
Raquel Welch and Burt Reynolds and this
was during Franco's time and Burt
Reynolds I mean Burt Rose was a good
athlete very good athlete from Florida
State yes
but Jim Brown was just I mean he's Jim
Brown he's one of the few specimen in
the world to reach that level he could
have done anything we threw the football
to each other and threw the discus he
threw a new track and field as well and
we had a few political arguments but
interesting intense arguments at the
time was the height of Vietnam had of
civil rights and I have nothing but the
greatest respect and then years later we
play tennis
my tennis matches tennis and he was as
competitive as I am you know or use even
more competitive I think of it so yeah
we play tennis I know he's in the reason
lacrosse Hall of Fame right I know that
he's one of the greatest lacrosse
players in the history sure huge right
yes he's one of the Syracuse's greatest
football and lacrosse players racked and
I've never heard tennis I haven't seen
Jim oh dude he that guy I pick up any
sport see what a compete does compete
okay what it is mm-hm just compete I
don't care what it is
show me the game I practiced for a while
then I compete with you so in that sense
we were you know brothers Eric I'd love
having you on man I'll be damned
which is a book written by a guy I'm
just looking at the back you've got
Tavis Smiley and James Cameron Bill
Maher writing some testimonies and then
Stephen a Smith receiving a I think they
after tomorrow mm-hmm is it oh he cou
where you seeing em we're gonna have
dinner together you and Stephen a yeah
we Tom we said hello I will definitely
do that will you play the drum will you
play the drop for for him we've been
that was when that was when he porzingis
yeah we've been what do you say we
better be nearing what is it I'd winked
play it one more time and do a 42 you
know here can you read my hand which
isin do a 40 I would do that by the way
I'm gonna be there with a stopwatch okay
I don't can you read my handwriting
we've been hoodwinked bamboozled led
astray run amok and flat-out deceived
you got that you can you do that is
Victor Victor Newman hit as we go to
break hit it hit it Mike del to foe
we have been hoodwinked bamboozled then
astray I can't ride your ride and rear
am riding yes that's flat-out deceived
not deceive run amok what run amok
running up the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience